[Musique]
dit j'aimerais qu'on accueille tout de
suite lignot et sa mère céline parce que
jude law ont fait une surprise
incroyable idiot et sa mère série qui
sont allés
un désamour merci des prières savamment
vidéo c'était pas trop manqué non tu
t'en fous de moi ça va moins chez reed à
moi ça va merci d'être là guillot il est
fan de jul il est fan de jul il est
paraplégique depuis sa petite enfance 8
ensuite un vaccin
georgi fès a rencontré hier je suis je
l'aimais vraiment je les adore il est
exceptionnel et il adore tout ce qui
passe chaque équipe et vous avez créé
une association lilio lange
il y b 1 et c'est essais afin de venir
en aide à votre fils et améliorer son
confort de vie et lilio hier il est venu
boire
ils pensaient avoir rendez-vous chez le
médecin et en fait c'était pas du tout
ça et c'est son anniversaire qui arrive
bientôt c'est lui janvier
on voulait lui faire une belle surprise
regardez
bonjour docteur bonjour
vous êtes venu avec lio oui mais là vous
allez bolides et au tuba reconnaît ou
pas je suis pas docteur suis pas docteur
mais il n'y a pas d'eau faire
aujourd'hui bon j'ai une surprise pour
toi ça te dirait d'aller avec la famille
au concert de djoulfa mécontents chez
rien et la commune iv tu vas voir tu est
une surprise pour toi après leur vie
[Musique]
quand tu sais que sir i need a dit qu'il
allait avoir une autre surprise pour toi
ô combien sur couze
[Musique]
aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à temps
regardez à pied pour mettre le feu
[Musique]
je me dis moi
pavages litres remercier tout ce que tu
as fait pour les lions
ce qu'on attendait pour lui je pense
qu'il va s'en souvenir
messi
m
[Musique]
et je voulais vraiment remercier jul et
toute son équipe ont été formidables
ajouté un mec te gêne énormément qui est
formidable et satisfaire des quotas t'as
kiffé le concert 1
on m'appelle c'est parti sur le béton si
les causes qui les accueille son veto
elle colonise encombrant il pas content
non ma chérie tu viens me voir quand
bientôt quand tu veux j'invite tous les
jours tu es en bas je te fais un gros
bisou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]